hey you guys movie retrospective time i
tried to be all slick that time instead
of being all enthusiastic you know what
i mean i guess so
you guess he doesn't know what a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
this was a good movie you had never seen
this had you i've never seen this movie
and um if you're a fan of uh
night of the living dead [ __ ] george
romero this is very much like not a
living dead it's a pandemic movie it's
kind of like a zombie movie
kind of like the original concept of the
rage zombie
except
the disease the the bio weapon it gets
out it makes people crazy
and which is kind of like a rage zombie
but they also do funny [ __ ] too like try
to sweep the grass and they just do they
do [ __ ] doesn't make any sense
and it's kind of like a zombie movie
but it allows for um
kind of like uh
unexpected stuff to happen it's a good
movie
yeah i actually had forgotten i saw this
movie probably like 25 30 years ago and
i remember like liking it but not loving
it but i liked it much better this time
i think i appreciated it a lot more in
color it's like night of living dead but
it's in color
it's a similar theme i think it's more
similar to dawn of the dead yeah um but
not as funny not as fun not as zany but
the tone is more like night of the
living dead yeah so it's interesting
that this is kind of like in between
this is the crazies yeah and one of the
houses that they actually are in is i
think it's the same movie from there it
looks like the same house i mean it's
like i was on like i did a little bit of
research but i couldn't really find
anything about that but i'm pretty sure
that's the same house or i mean it might
have been because it's the same
staircase the same man it does i mean it
could be that you know it was just like
another house in the same and they kind
of built them all to look the same so
they all look similar but to me it
looked like the same exact house i'm not
i'm not close enough
close enough yeah so this is the crazies
from 1973. interestingly uh this is on
2b if you want to watch it uh the one
that's on 2b has the original title card
which was code name trixie uh it was
retitled the crazies later on you know
because of various distribution things
they were trying to get more people to
come in they thought that was a punchier
title i guess
um so this was remade in 2010 um which i
think i saw but you know we'll kind of
talk about that in a little bit because
it's not really all that similar uh so
this came out in 1973.
this is pretty much i think this was his
second feature film because night of
living dead was the first one that was
1968 and then so this is almost kind of
like bridging the gap between night of
the living dead and dawn of the dead
although he made martin in there too but
that's kind of like thematically
different that's more like a vampire
psychological type of movie whereas this
one is much more it's like a zombie
movie but not because the people are
like you said it's kind of like what
they would do in 28 days later you know
this which is obviously uh influenced by
this where it's a virus that makes
people crazy so they're not dead people
yeah it's just making them crazy and
they have some [ __ ] in here it looks
like it was kind of taking a little bit
out of the walking dead the first first
season of the walking dead you have
these two ex-army guys one on exec
special forces the other guy was
infantry
and them trying to protect their
girlfriends and some of their friends
from the us army infantry that's coming
in there and mop gear would kind of like
with with
mob gear is like a mission-oriented
mission or oriented protective posture
that's that damn
you guys know it's like bio gear
chemical biological warfare gear they're
in that
and they're going into this basically
deserted neighborhood and they're just
mowing everybody down they're trying to
stop this damn outbreak they're even
threatening to use the [ __ ] atomic
bomb
to [ __ ] fry this whole [ __ ] area
to keep this [ __ ]
rage or crazy virus from [ __ ]
spreading
and it's a bio weapon they made it it
got out
it's pretty good yeah yeah it's pretty
good because it shows
them these ex military guys trying to
survive and they're doing they start
doing some morally grey [ __ ] you know
but [ __ ] they didn't have any choice
because they were they were gonna get
killed
um
by the by the infantry and uh then it
also shows their leadership
some of the guys in the [ __ ]
uh in the basically like the weapons lab
and and the the units that are trying to
stop the outbreak so it's kind of like
two and there's kind of good guys on
both sides they're just trying to
stop this outbreak well it's interesting
because you can see like you said it's a
very morally grey movie and it's very
downbeat which a lot of uh romero's
movies were
in the sense that there's kind of like a
hopeless uh you know thing to the whole
uh affair you know the way that it ends
and stuff but you know which is kind of
like something that he did a lot but the
thing about it is that you understand
every single decision that the people
are making even though like some of it's
not great and it's you know some you
know [ __ ] like that mowing down
civilians and [ __ ] right but it's like
in a way like you can understand why
they did why they did that so again this
is set in uh like most of romero's
movies were set in pennsylvania because
that's where he's from yeah
before you get into it if you like night
of living dead and dawn of the dead and
all that
this fits right in there with them
yeah like i said it's not a zombie movie
but it's similar enough it's like the
same universe and a very similar tone to
the first one night of living dead
and similar to almost kind of like day
of the dead it it's similar to all of
them it's well yeah it's still romero
and he has a style
it's almost you can tell it's part of
that universe yeah yeah and so okay so
this was actually shot in evans city
pennsylvania which i think is like a
real pretty small town like uh about 30
miles from pittsburgh and uh i guess he
went there and shot it and they got like
pretty much all the townsfolk in on it
because this movie was like super cheap
to make and everybody was like woo we're
all going to be in a movie because
there's [ __ ] tons of extras in there
yeah and it's kind of a good thing it's
shot on location real locations real
people
some of the people really do a good job
acting other ones are just kind of like
good enough yeah but that was like night
of living dead too remember the guys in
the damn militia they were catching all
the zombies oh they're all messed up you
know that's all ad-lib and all ad-libbed
and it [ __ ] came across real good you
see a lot of that in this too
yeah it's kind of the same sort of thing
like i said it's there's some actors in
there that you've seen in other movies
like you know we're actually actors and
actually the one dude that plays uh the
doctor dr watts i think the guy that's
like yelling and like trying to find a
cure or whatever that dude was also that
dude was indonesia or day of the dead he
yeah i think he was i think he was in
day of the dead but he was in like some
other romero movies as well i love that
i love that dude
interesting special effects all
practical effects there's one shot where
they have a [ __ ] head a [ __ ] us
army guy his [ __ ] mask his mask and
his chemical gear right there and and
the it's right in front of the camera
and you can see a [ __ ] bullet hit it
and the thing [ __ ] blow up [ __ ]
blood and [ __ ] that was a real rifle
shot
it wasn't a real head but it was a real
real
first time i've actually seen realism
yeah
that was some old school [ __ ] they just
got underneath there with the camera and
could shoot it and they got it on camera
you know it's the first uh hollywood
wouldn't have the balls really to do
that i've never seen him use live ammo
in a hollywood movie well this this is
some homemade [ __ ] well yeah i mean it
looked good
they shot this movie for like you know
for almost nothing yeah well whoever
took that shot you know what i mean
[ __ ] that you had to trust him i'm
sure the camera was just set up running
there probably anybody under there well
yeah i mean just really need to man the
camera but the camera [ __ ] caught
that [ __ ] bullet going into that
thing when it happened me and jenny were
shocked right
because there's a big difference between
a real bullet impact and just a squib
round yeah which is just blood in a
blood packet no it looked good i was
like damn that was real
yeah i mean you don't get like like i
said this isn't a zombie movie so you
don't get all the gore but you do get
like a lot of uh people getting shot
like a lot of bloody kind of [ __ ] yeah
um you know and some people are burned
and [ __ ] like that but you know so like
i said
yeah so it's a shot in a small town uh
kind of your main
good guy characters you want to call him
that uh it's two firefighters like one
dude named david he has a girlfriend
named judy who's pregnant um and then he
has a buddy whose name is clank which i
think is really funny i don't even know
if they say that in the movie i just
knew because i looked it up but yeah
like you said they're both uh veterans
now they're kind of like because the
girlfriend uh is a nurse judy is a nurse
so they kind of uh twig onto the fact
like pretty soon like pretty quickly
that something weird is going on in the
town the first thing that happens the
thing that's about this movie and i
think that romero uh kind of did this a
lot and he was maybe i don't think he
was the first person to do this but
that real quick editing style he has
which like i said in the 70s you didn't
really see that uh too much nowadays
everything's like super fast edited
because everyone has 80d and they're
like come on come on come on but it's
like you didn't really see that much in
the 70s but this one um is like the
editing is like really really fast and
like really really choppy but the thing
about it is that it really like informs
this whole story because this whole
movie and i didn't appreciate this i
think the first time that i saw it was
just this whole movie is just like a
chaotic mess which is what it would be
like in real life if this happened so i
think like the editing really goes a
long way towards just showing how nobody
knows what the [ __ ] is happening
everyone is confused and yelling it's
like no one knows what to do it's
survival horror yeah and stuff like that
so the way that it just kind of goes
like from person to person and like
sometimes there's shots where there's
just like a bunch of people like yelling
what this guy's yelling in a phone over
here this guy's yelling at this dude
over here and it's all like overlapping
and it really has a um has this whole
like kind of
you know atmosphere of panic yeah
there's another thing that they did that
was real well it has a real good
post-apocalyptic feel to it especially
when they're running around on their own
in more desolate area areas out in the
farms and and fields and then just going
into abandoned houses and stuff and
abandoned stores so they we're doing
[ __ ] like that just
you know it's all real fresh it's not
like mad max level where you know it has
something that happened a long time ago
everything's still stocked
this is kind of a good
concept you know what i mean in a lot of
old-fashioned interiors that you would
only see in the 70s
from the 50s still around um
kind of had that damn dead mall feel to
it or something like an urbex like urban
urban exploration kind of video feel to
it
it's definitely real low budget but
there's kind of like a homemade charm to
it it feels real
it it feels real what do you call the
tone is very authentic
in a weird way you can tell that it's an
act and they're putting on a show
but you can also kind of tell if they
cared about what they were doing it was
it's just kind of cool that they were
having fun with it well i think that's
what a lot of people even like a lot of
younger horror fans like about 70s
horror is that even if the acting isn't
like up to snuff or even if things
aren't or even if the special effects
aren't realistic yeah there is some kind
of like weird gritty yeah
auteurs have like like almost like snuff
movie kind of like feel to it you know
what i mean that i think like lends i
think something to the authenticity i
think the authenticity come feel kind of
comes from the fact that
you know and they know that this is a
movie and you're both in on this
together you're suspending your
disbelief because they're telling you a
good story they showed you some wild
[ __ ] you weren't supposed to really
believe that was a real person on fire
that doesn't matter it's kind of like a
make-believe thing
but there's still something kind of
authentic about it you can identify with
the filmmakers
the the filmmaker is a person like you
working in a neighborhood like your
neighborhood
hiring people who are kind of like the
people you hang out with to do these
[ __ ] roles a lot of times so there's
something about kind of like you feel
like you're getting on the joke you know
we're not in a joke but you know in on
the show
yeah feel like it was made for you by
your friends it's just kind of what it
feels like well it comes up particularly
romero's movies from this era they
really do come off as like this this was
like a scene yeah because he used a lot
of locals he used you know from the
local theater scene um you know a lot of
the people just that just lived there
that wanted to be in the movies so he
really kind of like you know used a lot
of his friends and like local talent
yeah and so you can really so that
really kind of like comes across as
we're all going to get together and make
a movie type of
thing and you as the audience seem to be
kind of like you feel like you've been
recruited in on this project to watch it
that's just what it feels like yeah i
know yeah
that's a good way of putting it actually
but yeah so i i forgot to say like at
the very beginning of this like i said
if you don't know that this is like an
outbreak movie um it's kind of good
because for a long time like for maybe
like the first half you know half of the
movie they don't really nobody really
knows exactly like nobody in the town
knows exactly what's going on at the
very beginning you just had these two
kids in a house and they're kind of
hiding from one another and you know
doing all this other kind of [ __ ] but
then they see their dad just going
absolutely [ __ ] ape [ __ ] in the house
like smashing all this kind of stuff and
they're like what the [ __ ] and so they
go up and like find their mom and their
mom has been stabbed to death and then
their dad sets the [ __ ] house on fire
with the little two kids in there so the
two kids being brought into the hospital
and the dad being brought in and just
like acting like a gibbering
idiot um so they're just like what the
[ __ ] is going on with this and that's
kind of how the [ __ ] kicks off now it
turns out later on you find out as it
goes on like the military pretty much
comes into the town and starts we're
just like okay we need to cordon this
whole town off nobody can leave uh
they're going in people's houses and
just being like we're taking everybody
to the high school because we have to
keep every we have to keep everybody
contained and it comes to light that
what ended up happening
was that six days prior to the dude
burning down the farmhouse um
a military plane which contained a
essentially a bio weapon
called trixie crashed into like a lake
or something like that so this bio
weapon which makes people which either
kills people outright or makes them just
go batshit insane uh has gotten into the
water supply now the interesting thing
about this and they think they bring
this up like one of the military guys
like brings this up they're like dude
the plane crashed like six days ago um
and it's like we finally got here we
finally figured out what was going on
and we're cordoning off the area but
who's to say that there wasn't some
trucker coming through here who drank
some water and then took off so it's
like all of their efforts
might be completely useless because it's
like i'm sure it probably would have
escaped by then because like in the six
days inter like some infected person
probably went through the town or like
escaped or whatever especially within
the water supply so like i said there's
that's what i mean about this being like
kind of downbeat or being like a thing
where it's like because even when the
military guys get there
um you know it and they seem like and
they seem like bad guys because they're
dragging these people out of the house
and like kind of corralling everybody to
the high school they bring in scientists
to try to like work on a cure or
whatever so they are like trying to fix
the problem but they're like well on the
other hand we can't let this get out
like farther than this small town or
we're all going to be hosed so they so
they really have to kind of make a lot
of hard decisions and they don't and
none of them really seem to know
what's going on like because there's a
lot of information like the the top
brass or whatever aren't sharing with
them so it's like this whole chaotic
like know what's like i don't know
that's what i mean so so in a way like
it's this realistic if this really
happened in a small town like this bio
weapon they didn't want to get out this
is pretty much exactly how [ __ ] would go
and we and and that whole element okay
the whole stop in the pandemic or
stopping the outbreak thing was done by
a military unit commanded by this
colonel he's played by his black dude
who's [ __ ] good he's like one of the
best actors in this there's two really
good actors the dude who plays the
cardinal and he represents the the
outbreak stoppers and then the special
forces guy who is the [ __ ] the outbreak
i'm gonna try to save my family those
two dudes right there are the two main
leads and one guy's got one mission and
the other guy's got another mission
um
romero romero was real good about
casting people
who were the strongest you know what i
mean he's not really
like for instance night of the living
dead you know the dude who [ __ ] ran
that movie was that other black dude hey
remember that uh-huh and he wasn't
really cast as a bag dude he just put
his best actor in the lead and he
[ __ ] carried that whole flick that's
kind of what they did here that when i
when i say that the movie kind of has
authentic feels because you could tell
that
it's organic it doesn't have any
corporate sponsorship they're not trying
to sell you a product
um there's no product placement
and everything is kind of like people
are cast
just kind of naturally based upon what
their natural skills are and it works it
works really well you know uh
you can tell there's no kind of like
corporate or political agenda behind any
of this [ __ ] he's just trying to get his
vision done
you know like the good-looking girl is
cast by a good-looking girl you know you
don't take a an ugly girl make her the
good-looking girl no it's a good-looking
girl you know what i mean it's just
something funny about it you know it's
just it's the way old movies were
sometimes made well the thing about
romero politics yeah but romero was had
a lot of social commentary in his uh
yeah but it was his big time but it was
his it wasn't
a corporate sponsorship it wasn't
political or anything from other
political it was his commentary his
political commentary so it felt very
he wasn't hired to give somebody else's
commentary he was doing his own so it
felt very authentic that's what i meant
by it but yeah so well one thing he was
kind of saying about
well no no i'm just
yeah
you know i get what you're saying yeah
yeah it felt like he
that he's really doing his vision and
you
when you're watching it you're like yeah
okay you buy it you buy it because he
believes what he's telling you
one thing i thought was really
interesting about this
is that like i said even
the cool thing about this and one of the
things that i think the remake [ __ ] up
um the remake is an okay movie um but
they changed something that i think uh
made this one a lot creepier or a lot
more effective
what they did in the 2010 remake was
that they made the people that got the
virus you immediately knew that they got
device they started looking like which
like i said they probably ripped off
from 28 days later which had come out
and whenever that came out 2002 or
something like that um where it's like
they had [ __ ] up looking eyes and
their skin started going [ __ ] up the
thing about the original
is that you don't know
who's infected or not
so
in a way that makes it a lot more tense
because not only do you have these
townspeople that are just like what the
[ __ ] like all this military came in and
they just declared martial law and won't
tell anybody what's going on then
they're hurting them all into this high
school so you have all the military guys
and then you have so you have some
townspeople who are like farmers and
[ __ ] like that who are also armed and
are like yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] we're like
gonna you know shoot back at you and
then you also have military guys who are
just wearing you know the oompa loompa
like outfits and you don't know you
can't see their faces because of the gas
mask some of them might be infected too
so it's like you don't know who's crazy
and who's not and so in a way i think
that's like really
creepier because it's like the crazy
people don't look like rage zombies they
just look like a regular ass person
and then they just start like very very
slowly it starts to because like i said
the hot chick that's in this she starts
to go crazy who yeah now she's the same
woman that was in she was in like some
cronenberg uh movies right she was and i
think she was in shivers was she not
yeah i think she was in shivers uh do
you recognize her she's been in a ton of
uh [ __ ] got a very unique face she's
cute yeah you know but
you don't see people that look like that
much anymore
yeah i guess that's not movies but yeah
so so she's in this
and her and her dad
are kind of like join forces with the
two firefighters and the and the
pregnant nurse and you know we're kind
of but as the movie goes on the teenage
daughter she's playing a teenage
daughter even though i think she's a
little bit older than that but she's
supposed to be a teenager um she just
very very slowly starts to act a little
bit weird like somebody's like she sees
a bunch of people get shot and she like
starts laughing at it the dad's like
she's fine she's fine you know i mean so
you know zombie flick when a person
turns they're a zombie
yeah this one that's about it's a shade
of gray
it can be crazy but not that crazy
they're infected and it just gets worse
as it goes off yeah so it's like you're
not entirely sure at first right just
because they're a little bit crazy that
doesn't mean you have to kill them right
you know what i mean so in the zombie
flick you'd have to kill a person as
soon as they yeah they're like oh wow
that's enough for you but the rules are
a little bit different because now it's
kind everything's kind of gray
you're like yeah they're crazy but
they're not really hurting anybody
and also they're working on a vaccine
too and like i said it's kind of like
and that's why i kind of like this
frenetic editing because it kind of
gives a sense of the chaotic
[ __ ] that's going to like no one knows
exactly what's going on um so it's just
kind of like everyone's confused
everyone's running around it's like why
the military shooting at us you know and
then you have all crazy people running
around it's like are they just crazy or
are they just mad because the military's
here and they're fighting back so you
don't really you know are the military
guys shooting at people because they
have the crazy virus or are they just
doing that because they're all because
that's what or
or is it both so that's what i mean so
it's like anybody could get it yeah
because it's super super contagious and
you don't know because there's no it's
not like you know it's not like 28 days
later when as soon as you get the blood
in your mouth you're like and you like
you know bust out and i think
and i think that's what they did in the
remake too because i saw um you know i
haven't seen it a long time i'm pretty
sure i saw it but it's just kind of like
i saw some stills from it and basically
when you get the disease it makes you
look different so you know so everybody
knows to stay away from your ass this
one not so much
um like i said it's just like little
things at first and you're just like
wait are they infected or are they just
like acting a little quirky right now or
we don't really know it's like i said
it's kind of like it's on us it's on a
spectrum yeah which to me is like a lot
creepier it's more also more realistic
yeah exactly a lot more realistic it's
like they're not gonna dry they're not
gonna look like oh i got red contact
lenses now and it's like you know you
have a group of people running at you
some of them might have guns and they're
shooting at you
some of them just might be running and
they got a broom and they're sweeping
yeah she's sweeping the field
[Laughter]
so you know because they're [ __ ]
crazy you know
and just because they're crazy doesn't
necessarily mean that they're dangerous
they're dangerous right uh some of them
are dangerous to themselves like a guy
running you know and then he pours
gasoline on himself and sets himself on
fire what's that got to do with you
nothing but the [ __ ] was crazy
yeah you know what i mean and then you
got
your girlfriend and she's slowly she's
slipping she's getting crazier and
crazier but she's not hurting anybody
she's just getting [ __ ] crazy talking
about getting married or whatever you
know i talk about having babies and [ __ ]
you're getting attacked by these people
and she's talking about naming the baby
there's no baby you know what i mean
it's just
well she was pregnant though she was
pregnant but
they're getting attacked and there's no
the baby hasn't didn't come so there's
no baby yet yeah i mean she's talking
so it's inappropriate behavior not
necessarily threatening behavior what
are you going to do you're going to plug
your girlfriend just [ __ ] blow her
head off no
yeah now you got a defender so it's a
lot more it's a lot more complicated
yeah which in a way like the more i
think about it like the more genius uh
that premise is
that you don't really know and like you
said it's not because you don't know how
the madness how the virus is gonna
manifest right because it manifests
different like for everybody and they
weren't really sure how it was spreading
well they did say it was airborne they
said it was airborne um but it was in
the water initially but they said it was
also airborne so they were using like
that uv light uh because they thought
that that maybe that would kill it or
keep it out of the air um but they were
kind of trying to like filter the water
and [ __ ] like that too but uh it's much
like romero's like usual stuff like i
said his his shit's like generally
pretty downbeat like i said the end of
the night and at night of the living
dead probably the most egregious example
of that we're just like hey everything's
okay and all the zombies are just oh and
then they plug the like the the hero
that made it through the [ __ ] [ __ ] uh
similar kind of [ __ ] happens here um and
this is one scene that i actually did
remember from the first time that i saw
it because like i said the uh the dude
dr watts that was working on uh you know
a vaccine or something like to fight it
he was looking for someone immune or
whatever he was working in the high
school they set him up he didn't have
all his equipment he was just like
constantly yelling and yelling at
everybody over the cb and the phone and
everything because he didn't have the
[ __ ] he needed he needed but then like
he finally worked it out and he's like
oh i think this is it i think this is it
and he goes out of the you know bio lab
or whatever like at the high school and
the military that are there don't know
who he is because all the other
townsfolk are also in the high school
and they're all just kind of milling
around some of them are crazy some of
them you don't know if they're crazy
they're just milling around because they
don't know what the [ __ ] going on and
so he's out going be like look i've been
working on this [ __ ] i've more and
they're just like yeah yeah just get in
there whatever and then he gets like
kind of uh swept up in the crowd some of
whom were crazy some of them maybe not
and he ends up getting knocked down the
stairs and dying and like breaking the
[ __ ] [ __ ] so it's just kind of like
that was the their their chance for a
vaccine and it's like all [ __ ] up just
because of like stupidity and
misunderstanding yeah um the the guys
that were doing the um the military guys
who were trying to start to stop the
outbreak
kind of have the same function
as the television in night of the living
dead yeah it has a lot of that same tone
except it's a lot more expanded and has
a lot more expanded characters in it
but if you notice that they were kind of
a lot like the television yeah from
that's well
they're providing exposition exposition
and to show you and then there's
authorities trying to do [ __ ] but
they're [ __ ] up you know what i mean
as usual
well like i said it's a great movie it's
a great movie i put it right there okay
it's
hard it's almost impossible to to beat
night of the living dead i mean it's a
[ __ ] masterpiece it's a masterpiece
but it's real similar real similar to
that
uh you can tell that it's the same
director it's the same people making it
oh yeah big time um
i'd probably say
it is similar
but it has a lot of elements that you
you saw in um
uh dawn of the dead yeah
not so much day of the dead but dawn of
the dead yeah i mean i feel like
you can yeah you can tell that this one
was in the middle between the living
dead
because it has like a serious survival
tone like that yeah i feel like dawn of
the dead had a little bit more levity
like it had a little bit more humor in
it this one not so much there's not
there's a little bit of humor like the
woman like sweep in the field and [ __ ]
like that but not like you know laugh
out loud funny there's like a a couple
little things but it's not plausible
it's all plausible yeah and like i said
it's just kind of like if it's kind of
scary to think but it's like if
something like this did happen in this
small town this is essentially how it
would get no one would know what the
[ __ ] was going on everything would be
like there'd be horrible
miscommunication and all this other kind
of stuff and it would just be a huge
[ __ ] and he really is uh you know
through the editing and everything uh
you know these kind of chaotic scenes of
everyone yelling like and having
different conversations in the same room
um you know that's pretty much exactly
how it would go and it's like really
really uh sad and it's like a little bit
scary too and like i said
if something like this happened it's
like you couldn't tell
if the people were crazy like you know
this the military guys go in this one
house and you know there's this old
woman sitting there like playing the
piano and then all of a sudden she flips
out and like starts [ __ ] stabbing him
with a knitting needle [ __ ] like that
then you have the whole scene which
i totally i watched this and i was like
ew i forgot this was in here but it's
like the whole scene where the dad and
the teenage daughter that are with like
the the hero group that are trying to
like get out of town
um and they kind of hole up in this
farmhouse and the dad and the daughter
are both kind of like afflicted not
entirely but it's still starting to
affect them and basically the dad and
the daughters are [ __ ] yeah
so you know
there's some incest going on yeah they
were crazy and then the guy saw that
they they started whipping his ass but
they realized that they're crazy
well and and the dad it's sad too
because the dad was like aware enough
like like after he got his ass beat he
was just like oh my god i just had sex
with my daughter and then he hung
himself yeah
because you know he he so he was still
like you know still there enough to
realize yeah i think the daughter forgot
about it
well she yeah she did she just kind of
well she had been like exhibiting
symptoms of craziness more like pretty
much from the beginning yeah she was
like inappropriate laughter and kind of
wanted to go up and talk to the soldiers
yeah even though they were like shooting
at people she was like i just want to go
talk to them it's
yeah so so she was kind of like wigged
out from the beginning yeah she died was
it was was was interesting too but it
has like a uh um
it i liked it i liked it it's it
like i said you can't beat night living
dead okay um
but it's you can you can tell it's right
there
in between night of living dead and dawn
of the dead and i didn't know about the
movie now i want it i want it on blu-ray
yeah i thought you probably liked it and
i feel like this is one um i didn't know
that a lot of george romero fans like
don't
haven't seen like i was watching there's
a lot of reviews of this because i think
arrow or somebody like that just did a
really nice blu-ray transfer like a few
years back
and um so i kind of feel like even a lot
of younger viewers are like you know
they're really into like romero zombie
movies but a lot of them haven't seen a
lot of his non-zombie movies like the
crazies or martin or something like that
like i said this one is much more like a
zombie movie than obviously martin is
nothing like a zombie movie that's more
like a vampire you know
it is a zombie movie but this is
essentially a zombie movie but you can't
tell who the zombies are yeah and the
people are still alive it's just a
modified version of like the rage zombie
idea except it's not rage it's random
it's just random craziness yeah
so you know even better so you don't
even know like how the people are gonna
yeah they're you can't you can't trust
them because like i said 28 days later
you know danny boyle's movie um which
i'm pretty sure we've reviewed that but
uh that's obviously like uh inspired by
this although like i said that virus one
it worked immediately and two it made
everybody angry and want to kill people
this one like i said it's a lot more
chaotic than it's a lot more yeah
because and you can't really tell who
has it and who was like if they're not
sure should you kill them
yeah because like well they're not
really doing anything yeah some aren't
really doing anything so it's not so cut
and dry which adds to the chaos
yeah and i had forgotten again i had
forgotten like the chaotic editing of
this but i think it really really like
uh it really helps like i said this is a
movie from the early 70s you know it's
very low budget um so you know it's
gonna be and some of the acting is kind
of you know whatever but
and it's very of its time but i feel
like if you are into romero zombie
movies and you've never seen this then
you should totally watch it because it's
totally along the same lines even though
it's not like the edit the edits in a
way are kind of similar
it's actually kind of similar to the
night of living dead yeah just in its
color yeah and it's a broader scope
friends for instance they're in that
house i'm pretty sure it's that same
house but they leave it and they go
around town yeah it's like a whole town
so they're you know they're they show
the whole town and they're trying to get
out of town right and they're trying to
survive in it it's kind of like a little
bit of an element of the walking dead
where they're running around towns and
stuff trying to survive yeah you can
definitely see how influential this was
um even though it didn't really do all
that well um george romero complained
because he's like oh you know the
distribution wasn't very well they
changed
yeah they changed the title a few times
like to try to get more people in but it
didn't do that well but it kind of like
developed a cult following over the
years like in the horror community and
you can definitely see how influential
this was on later outbreak movies and
later zombie movies also cool guns um
the army at the
carry all carrying 30 carbines
which um
if to be truthful about it you know this
is supposed to be taking place when uh
uh 68 72 73 73 70 by 73 it would have
all been m16s but
i don't know maybe a second rear echelon
unit you know in some kind of
hazmat
outfits might might have carried 30
carbines but
really you know you know that
with the budget that they had they
couldn't get m16s you could get a lot of
30 carbines those were kind of like the
ar-15s of the civilians for the days so
they got those but cool old [ __ ]
winchester 30 car beans with the wood
hand guards on the top and the bottom
and
um
he had a [ __ ] brownie high power
um i think there's some shotguns and
[ __ ] but just you know they're carrying
the old 30 carbine gear
web web gear um israeli gas masks and
stuff
he just he just did a good job just
trying to equip a lot of guys because
there's a lot of guys that are equipped
with guns
so with the budget that he had that's
that's what he could afford it's
actually pretty impressive like how many
like how many extras there are in this
and how you know the costuming and [ __ ]
like that is actually like uh pretty
amazing thing yeah they had they at
least had 15 uh 30 carbines
yeah they're mustard because these it's
in certain scenes there's at least 15 of
them on screen at for at one time yeah
and i'm sure they reused like yeah
but i think i i think in some of those
shots there's at least 10 or 15 of them
showing so getting your hand on that
many of them at once and they are real
gods because they shot that thing and
you could tell that was
that was a real bullet that hit that
fake head i wonder if they put like a
watermelon or something on there
and then put the gas mask over it that'd
be funny that's what i would do yeah
converting [ __ ] to bike fire can
sometimes be you know probably
could be a pain in the ass there were
some blank adapters you could get into
the 30 carbine as long as your master of
arms could keep the [ __ ] straight and
make sure that there are no [ __ ] live
rounds anywhere in set you could
you could do a 30 carbine pretty easily
um
m16 even more so they just change the
flash suppressor out to a blank adapter
suppressor
and put blanks in there
and uh easier to do but uh
yeah
pretty good pretty good feat to get that
much that many blank firing weapons on
screen at one time
for a small production for such a small
budget yeah it really does have a much
larger scope 30 carbines weren't really
that cheap in 73. yeah i'd be curious to
know exactly how much this i think maybe
this cost 200 grand or something yeah
or something like that i must have
rented them they must have rented those
yeah you know there's there's places
where you can do that kind of stuff so
it's it's maybe why but yeah so if
you're into romero's zombie movies and
you haven't seen any of his other movies
uh because he did make other kinds
but um yeah i would definitely check it
out it's on to be like i said it's
interesting because the version that's
on 2b actually has the original title
card which is codename trixie so it
doesn't say the crazies even though the
you know the little poster on there that
you click on says the crazies i think
they also have the remake on there like
i said that's an okay movie but it's not
it's a lot different than the original
it's more like a straight ahead zombie
movie whereas this one is kind of like a
zombie movie but not really it's more
like an outbreak type of movie and uh in
a way i think it's a lot more effective
because like i said you can't tell who
it is that's affected it's got a [ __ ]
ton of retro charm
yeah it's [ __ ] time yeah i think it's on
it might be on amazon prime too but i'm
not entirely sure you might have to pay
to rent it but i think it's like pretty
cheap but yeah um check it out it's
actually uh pretty entertaining and
that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we will see you guys on
the next one bye
you